so welcome to the podcast how about we
just start with your just quick
background sure so I'm Elizabeth Lyons
I'm the founder and CEO of science
exchange and I'm a cancer biologist by
training I did my PhD at the Institute
of cancer research in London and then
did a postdoc at the University of Miami
and became an assistant professor there
and then I left in 2011 to create
science exchange and that was part of
the 2011 summer batch of Y Combinator so
that's really where I first got involved
with Y Combinator and then have
subsequently continued to grow science
exchange in two years ago I joined as a
part-time partner which is now called
the expert program here to help out with
the biotech companies that were starting
to apply to Y Combinator okay and so
let's just get this out of the way a
very common question is like I'm a
biotech company like I'm a founder why
should I do oh I see yeah we definitely
get asked it a lot and I think these
kind of two camps one is that there are
people who are genuinely not heard of Y
Combinator previously so they asked Oh
what does Y Combinator why should I do
it more from a sense of I'm not sure
what this program is what will the
benefits be and so that's more a generic
answer of you know YC is a great
starting point for companies that you
know want to kick off their the launch
of their company successfully we provide
a lot of expertise and resources around
how to incorporate how to really focus
on building that first initial stage of
creating product market fit and getting
a company off the ground so there's that
kind of Avenue and that's usually PhD
students or postdocs who maybe haven't
you know been exposed to
entrepreneurship first and I think
that's a great program for them from
that aspect but then we definitely have
more established biotech or people who
are in the biotech world and they sort
of look at it like well why would I do
that or why would any biotech company
want to do that and really our answer
there is around you know the tremendous
access to capital and the expertise
around fundraising the opportunity to
interact with really different sectors
that you may not have been familiar with
so we have a very diverse
and cutting-edge group of companies that
are part of every single batch and so
you actually get access to things like
artificial intelligence all of the
technologies that are being developed in
different verticals you're exposed to
those as you're part of the program and
that can really benefit the companies in
interesting and unexpected ways as they
participate but one of the unexpected
ways is that there's been a lot of
crossover funding that has occurred for
the biotech companies so many of our
biotech companies have been able to
raise significantly more capital than
they would have been able to if they
just sort of stuck with the traditional
biotech venture world and not taking
part in the program and that's I think
an area where people didn't expect that
there would be such an appetite but
there has actually been over 200 million
dollars of capital raised for these
companies already mmm and so how how do
you see like a batch play out for an
average biotech company because one of
the main questions I get during office
hours is like you know why seize three
months long like what do I actually do
in three months you know this is like a
decade-long project how does it work out
normally yes so normally the companies
similarly actually to any I think
enterprise company right so most
enterprise companies are not going to be
making really significant sort of
fundamental advancements in a
three-month program either but what Y
Combinator does is it provides that
focus to really hone what is the company
doing what's the minimal Viable Product
that's required to get you know to the
next stage and so for us a lot of our
biotech companies are genuinely able to
figure out what does they go to market
strategy very efficiently in the program
and then execute against that so they
may not make you know really significant
advancement in terms of the experimental
work but they certainly will make a
significant advancement in terms of
understanding the market and
understanding what steps are required to
get to the market in a way that allows
them to the arrays funding and capital
that's required to take those steps and
that so that's a pretty there is a
pretty big deal in terms of just
figuring out what you need to do and
minimizing the noise and increasing the
focus on what you need to do mm-hmm and
so where do they put the money to work
during YC so it's not a lot of money so
exactly so they really put the main to
work through things like they may do
some initial critical path experiments
okay so if they can outsource those
experiments then they'll often be able
to get results quickly and we have had a
lot of success with that with our
biotech companies we've actually worked
with external companies that are already
up and running to do for example proof
of concept studies or efficacy studies
that they can then submit to the
regulated authorities to get approval of
the next stage we've seen companies work
with regulatory consultants to devise a
go to market strategy and make you know
significant advances in terms of their
filing status so definitely seen people
be able to use that time to actually
advance the company alongside with
really planning and talking to initial
customers and figuring out with with
their potential markets what would be
required you know at each stage to get
to the next level hmm and so you kind of
talked about like market and like
figuring out go to market and a lot of
these business like business ideas
basically do you find that a lot of
biotech companies are bringing on like a
business co-founder or are they just
like picking it up while they're going
through YC
I think they pick it up so I think
there's you know I think one of the
interesting differences between biotech
companies and sort of software just take
companies is that the actual market is
not really that that question like if
you're a biotech company and you're
going to cure out Simas disease there's
no question of whether that's gonna be
you know a great market that's obviously
going to create enormous value but the
question is more the technological risk
and how you do risk the actual
innovation that's being developed and so
for a lot of the time we're really
focused on that de-risking and figuring
out for the biotech companies what do
they need to do to really significantly
depress the technology as quickly as
possible
versus the software companies I think
there's Christians around market right
there is questions around how big could
this really get you know a lot of
Christians around execution strategy to
get to market as quickly as possible and
have a competitive differentiation over
others that are doing similar things
I mean those are more those fundamental
questions we are you know business
partners and marketing and growth
hackers and all those type of people
like coming to play but I think with the
science you know mostly the scientists
are I think feely
scientists people have this kind of
illusion that they're like antisocial or
like they don't understand business and
I I just like completely disagree with
that I think scientists have to be very
articulate they frequently present in
front of large audiences they write very
complicated grant funding strategies so
many of these you know everyday skill
sets are already present and scientific
stuff so it's I think actually like not
really a need to have a business
co-founder okay and by nature like so
many of these things are gigantic
markets if you have you know absolutely
so you said something that I didn't
fully understood what does that actually
mean over the course of the three months
yes OD risking is really around getting
experimental data or actually looking at
the go to market strategy for particular
technologies so mostly for de-risking
technology is things like showing in an
animal model that the therapeutic
intervention is able to cure the disease
or reduce the impact of the disease or
in a cell model or something like that
so you're really looking for those proof
points along the way so if you're
starting out and your goal is to cure
out summers disease then your initial
steps to get there will be to one come
up with a biological mechanism that you
think is plausible for the disease
you'll then need some sort of model
system to be able to test how your
intervention is going to impact that
biological mechanism and then you will
basically develop a therapeutic either
an antibody or or a medical device or a
small molecule inhibitor and you will
add that into the model and see whether
you actually improve the survival in
that particular model and then you'll
have to do basic studies around tox
toxicity studies that are required to
submit for an initial human studies so
basically
these steps happen before you're able to
go into the clinic and test and people
does my intervention really work to cure
Alzheimer's disease okay gotcha and so
in your experience you know when people
are applying to I see how far they
gotten along that process because I
imagine they're probably yeah a huge
spectrum and it's very interesting
because actually particularly the
earliest phase of discovery that is an
area where there's significant
underinvestment just generally in the
industry so everybody wants these you
know new molecules or new strategies
that are at the clinical stage so if you
have initial proof of concept data and a
clinical phase and then you're probably
already acquired right so there's like
oh yeah so I mean people like the pharma
companies are desperate for buying an
innovation and so they're really looking
for companies to get to that initial
proof of concept in a human and human
studies so that's really where a lot of
their innovation that's coming from as
biotechs that have got you know new
molecules through to that point and the
process
and the investment and that earliest
stage that's really a lot of challenges
like differently there's investment from
the academic setting but there's a huge
gap between what's done in academia and
then how do you to get it into the
clinic like that area of translation
it's called translational research is
dis increasing focus on it but it's
definitely an area where we see a lot of
companies apply so they apply when they
have you know some initial data that
suggests that they have you know an
interesting approach to studying to
curing a disease or to you know
developing for example a new way to test
for a particular disease so they're sort
of at that stage and then it's really
that going from the initial experimental
data the discovery through to actually
having some initial proof of concept and
the clinic that it works so that's the
gap where we really focus so then okay
so I yeah I don't have a PhD like I do
yeah
it's okay so walk me through like you
know say I'm doing a ph.d program which
she said seven years average the other
median is seven years yeah in u.s. in
the u.s. yeah because yours was like
three or four yeah okay yeah at what
point in the process would I start
thinking about okay maybe this is a
company versus like I'm just gonna round
out my seven seven years yeah and like
complete it
I don't like yeah yes I definitely want
to complete it of course at time I think
I think most people would want to
complete it but yeah so I think it's
when you're getting to the end of your
PhD you're thinking about what am I
going to do next of course like this the
excitement of you're finally finishing
after all this time it's time to go do
something else and traditionally that
next thing was always the postdoc so if
you were going to become a professor and
be an academic investigator you would go
to a postdoc and that's um that's a
that's a big shift that's happened
recently and this is this is pretty well
known phenomenon called the postdoc
ellipse that Ethan Pilsen came up with
which is this concept that there's so
many postdocs now and no jobs for them
so there's just nowhere for them to go
in terms of staying as an assistant
professor or a professor and academia
and so instead you have to look for what
are the alternative paths and you've
already invested all this time and
energy into your research and not all of
it will be relevant to starting a
company but there's definitely people
who've made some pretty significant
advancements in that period of time and
they have something that might be
commercially valuable and so for them
the question is you know do you go
forward and just continue in academia
and probably if you do that you'll work
on something different because you
usually switch labs and go and work on
something different for your postdoc or
perhaps you can think about taking that
idea and that discovery and thinking
about an entrepreneurship opportunity to
turn that into a company and there's
more and more acceptance of that
strategy obviously so people have
realized that you know leaving academia
and going into industry is not it's not
so evil
as it was once thought of because the
reality is you know all innovations that
come to market through industry so you
know you don't see drugs on the market
that came from academia they were all
many of them discovered in the earliest
phases the basic research was done in
academia but then those were spun out
into commercial biotech companies or
pharmaceutical companies licensed them
and took them through to
commercialization and so that is a long
path very very expensive path and so I
think you know there's a big opportunity
for these students to think about you
know the discoveries have made and say
well maybe I want to create this into a
company and maybe there's a real
opportunity for me to actually take the
discovery I made and really use it in
the real world as opposed to just in the
academic setting which is often distance
from from the actual commercial
application of course yeah and are there
like other IP concerns that are specific
to biotech companies that someone's
thinking about absolutely so IP and
biotech is like very very critical and
this is something that's very
challenging actually with academia yeah
so intellectual property is you know
fundamentally the cornerstone of a
biotech strategy because you need to own
the intellectual property in order to
invest all of that development time and
money that's required to go through
clinical studies to get it out into the
market and then you need some window of
exclusivity around their intellectual
property to sell your compound before
some generic manufacturer comes and
sells it for $2 right so that's really
why IP is so important in the space it's
not because you know people are
inherently trying to be greedy it's just
that there's such a lot of dollars
invested in these molecules in the
development of them that then you need
some kind of time period at which you
can recover their investment or else is
just simply unsustainable there is no
path to actually developing those drugs
and in academia most intellectual
property is owned by the actual
University so when you yeah so when you
are working in a university your IP
belongs to the University and and then
there is
there is a path to actually licensure
from the University and so essentially
you have to go through that process of
licensing the intellectual poverty to
develop the company for most PhD
students there is an exception where
they're not subject to it so it really
depends on the specific program and so
then that's another you know area of
complexity to have to research but but
for professors and postdocs definitely
the intellectual probably generated
there belongs to the University and so
how does that work for an average YC
company do they license it prior to YC
yes so they not always prior they will
have you know one of the things we do
during the program has helped them with
strategies around licensing intellectual
property figuring out you know who can
they work with to do that like how does
it work at the university so there's a
tech transfer office in a sponsored
research office at each University and
so you have to interact with them and
figure out you know a compelling
business case for why you know they
should license it to you and usually if
you're the discoverer then there is a
compelling business case for why they
should license it to you okay gotcha and
so then what about what about what
happens after the three month period
right like do we find like what's a
fundraising process like for a biotech
company yes really interesting actually
because we don't have tremendous amount
of data on this so far because the
program has only included biotechs for
the last couple of years but what has
been really interesting is that there is
a lot of appetite from early-stage
technology investors for funding biotech
and interesting science companies in
general I think we've seen you know many
companies raise pretty large rounds
straight out of YC from a seed funding
perspective so several million dollars
or more and then then it's that path of
how do you get to that next stage for
the institutional round so the Series A
round and we've only just started to
reach that point with several of the
companies and they are raising rounds so
we're definitely seeing success with
them being able to continue to fund
their companies even at the later stages
but we don't have you know a lot of
historical data to go back you know
three or four years we're only a
this of two year mark hmm do they tend
to raise from you know funds out here or
do they go you know are they raising
money in Germany like well how does it
how's it going Oh interesting
mostly here so definitely a lot of
Silicon Valley funds are doing
investments in this space so even funds
that people may not have thought about
traditionally so Khosla Ventures has
done a lot on Jason Horowitz has done a
lot data collective founders fund so
there's a lot of sort of funds like that
NEA
that are interested in you know science
and interested in not just software
applications but really interesting
companies that are combining you know
insights particularly from the software
world into the actual biological world
and so that's an area where there's been
a lot of interest in investment so it's
actually much more of like a traditional
fundraising path than I had thought
yeah yeah I don't know why I had figured
that it was coming from other sources
well this is in the in the biotech world
generally there's kind of two ways that
people raise money so one is if they are
sort of unknown yeah and they're young
and they haven't got any history of
doing successful biotech companies
before then that would be you know one
of the paths they do it is to come and
do something like Y Combinator gets some
area of of growth and D risk their
strategy right and then they can raise
money but what we've seen you know
historically and the biotech sector is
very much like the old school days of
raising funding as a software company we
are you know a lot of the funding was
going to repeat entrepreneurs people who
basically these funds will create
they'll basically license in a discovery
and then they'll created team internally
to develop that to a student stage and
then spin it out and put in a
professional team of like a professional
CEO and everything to to run the company
and so that's a much more common sort of
path that the biotech funds would take
to to developing companies so it's
almost like an internal incubation
strategy yeah that then spins out
companies and that's been effective
that's very effective I mean that's like
third Rock Atlas
Polaris flagship like this all of those
big funds take that strategy and it's
very successful they have created a lot
of you know the most well-funded and
recognized companies that you probably
have heard of a new biotech space but
there's also the opportunity to look at
the landscape you know in a more broad
setting which is what else is there like
if you just find no well if you just
fund like the same people over and over
again then yes they'll be like really
efficient they'll understand what it
takes to do this
but you'll also miss out on all of the
other innovative different thinkers who
are out there who actually made the
discoveries like the PhD students and
postdocs the ones who've actually made
the discoveries and so then if you can
provide a path for them to also
participate as founders and as
entrepreneurs they potentially have you
know a lot of inside knowledge about the
discoveries that they made that can help
this company succeed and what we're kind
of missing is the funding and the
mentorship because it is a steep
learning curve to navigate how you take
a drug to market through all of the
regulatory hurdles and so if we can
build you know path that supports those
people more effectively that's going to
be I think you know the killer's sort of
application it's going to be how do you
get a lot more of these shots on goal
and actually get a lot more people
involved in the biotech innovation
ecosystem developing companies and
bringing drugs to market and not just
staying in academia so how do you how do
you advise folks when that you know
maybe you do office hours or maybe do a
YC event or someone just emails you say
my PhD student like what's your advice
to me and I'm or I'm working on
something that I'm excited about but
like the whole thing is completely
foreign to me like we were talking about
before yeah you thought like or rather
you met with PhD students and they
thought the money that they raised was
alone wasn't an investment yeah like
they would have to pay it back yeah so I
think that it's like just an education
in the ecosystem thing we're I think if
you're a software developer you kind of
know about entrepreneurship it's become
such a central part of the ecosystem
that people just inherently
understand how does entrepreneurship
work like how do you start a company
what are the basics but that's not the
case for a lot of PhD students and
postdocs like they may not be exposed to
that world at all and so I found it very
interesting when I was talking to them
as we know when basically gave
presentations to for alternative careers
like there's this whole alternative
Korea's focus and the industry because
for PhD students and postdocs in
academia they're like I mentioned
there's not often a job path that exists
for them to become professors and so
there is actually a focus on saying what
other alternative careers are out there
and so obviously one of those
alternative careers is entrepreneurship
and so I've talked to some of these
groups and I really did get questions
like okay well you know what if my
company fails like will I have to pay
back that money will I be personally
liable I mean so just removing those
misconceptions like I can't even imagine
you know all of the like questions
around starting a company like you're
worried about like job path and what if
it doesn't work out and like will I be
able to get a job if it doesn't work out
like all those questions are still there
and scary but like you also have you
know so much misconception around even
things like you know I'd have to pay
back money that I raised like that's
that is to me a big red flag that like
this this particular sector just doesn't
even know what steps are required and
like doesn't understand the path to
being able to start a company and
doesn't realize that there's like real
there's real opportunity to do this in a
way that isn't as scary as it looks
right so if you take part in programs
like Y Combinator it really does sort of
provides you with the framework and the
confidence to know that you're
incorporating your company properly you
are not you know personally at risk when
you do this obviously if the company
fails in thing you have to think about
what other job you're going to do but I
mean at the same time there's like
there's a huge degree of risk of staying
in academia when you're at that stage in
your career because there's no job
certainty so you're definitely like
what's gonna be my nice job I don't know
I could be a postdoc forever which is
really differ
so is that is that what happened with
your um because you weren't you're in
Miami right when you started science
exchanges yeah what's happening with the
people you're working with like how
their careers progressed like alongside
yours yeah that's a good question I mean
I think a lot of them have done some
pretty interesting things actually so
one of the students that was NL labs
that he actually did start a biotech
company with my mentor so they started
up I'd see it coming together it's
pretty cool yeah so I definitely think
that there's you know more and more
people doing this and particularly if
they see other people doing it then it
gives them you know one person to ask
like how did you do that how did you
like figure out those nice tips can you
introduce me to people that can help me
like just having more colleagues that
have done similar things allows you to
to explore it as an opportunity for
yourself so and does that like are you
still reading journals what's what's the
cool stuff coming up I mean I guess you
read applications to for YC so maybe
there's like a particular focus what are
the things that are like right on the
edge you feel like you know that with
like 10 years realistically so like
reaching market that you're excited
about well there's a lot of things that
are really exciting at the moment and
you know I think science in general is
like a huge board area so I try to I try
to stay on top of the areas where I have
like the deepest understanding so cancer
biology is obviously for me an area of
intense interest and so we actually see
a lot of those new technologies and new
advancements through science exchange
actually because we set between
pharmaceutical companies that are
outsourcing their R&D through us
and we also work with lots of
early-stage biotech companies and then
on the other end we have all of these
actual service providers that are
running the experiments for them and so
we sort of see well that's interesting
like people are starting to do this
differently you're this time to think
about the next stage or they're looking
at this new therapeutic area and so I
think
they're very cutting edge that's mostly
still coming from academia so you're
seeing those in journals like science
nature cell and there's some really
interesting work that's happening but
for me the applied area that's probably
one of the more interesting areas is
looking at things like the application
of artificial intelligence and the
biological sector so there's some pretty
interesting work that's occurring around
how to be better at predicting efficacy
or toxicity in the preclinical stage so
you don't have clinical failures and so
there's a lot of innovation in that
space there's actually some interesting
innovation even in the design of
clinical studies so how to more quickly
get initial data and humans that will
tell you whether or not your application
is likely to work so historically people
would do you know phase one which is
basically just like a dose escalation
study where you're just looking for
toxicity and then you would do a much
larger study afterwards we were looking
for efficacy and so that's really time
consuming and expensive and people are
starting to say let's look for like
endpoints that we can use more quickly
and those initial first in human studies
that can give us a sense for whether our
targets are going to work and so I think
there's a lot of innovation in that
space which is pretty exciting and and
I'm sure you've seen like everyone's
talking about you know editing of human
embryos with CRISPR section so okay so
we're gonna call in like are you and get
very excited about CRISPR I mean CRISPR
is like game-changing it allows us to do
things that in the past we only dreamed
about I actually for my PhD I worked on
RNA i screens and RNA i screens were the
first technology where you could
basically inhibit gene expression that
you couldn't knock it out completely
okay so you would be you know
systematically knocking down the
expression of a gene maybe 50% or 60%
but over generations no no it's just in
real time so like but then a couple of
basically irony I works within like 48
hours and it's only transient unless you
create least stable cell lines but so
you can knock it down transiently and
then see the effect but it was so era
prone because you couldn't really
control it that well and you would you
would knock down Jeannie's mission like
fifty but seeing you would be like what
does it really mean versus if you knock
out the gene and it's no longer there
or you create a mutation that truncates
the gene and it's no longer expressed
then you're good right like it's gone so
you know for sure what is the functional
effect of doing so so we had you know we
had a ton of issues with artifacts and
you know challenges in that space with
RNA I but it did lay a lot of the
frameworks for some of the really
interesting applications with CRISPR now
not in the therapeutic space but doing
like high throughput screens where you
basically knock out every single gene
and for the first time you can do that
at scale and understand what is the
function of every single gene right so
it's incredibly powerful so where do you
think CRISPR like assuming everything
you know it gets tested it goes all the
way through where will it start to see
traction first so it mean it's already I
think there's some really interesting
applications that people are looking at
obviously the most the most obvious
application is to edit genetic defects
so if there's like a lethal genetic
defect being able to create that so
definitely there's a lot of innovation
in that space actually there was just a
recent application of it for RNA like
editing so that's the expression of the
genes so rather than editing the gene
itself editing the expression of the
gene kind of transiently
okay which is pretty interesting so I
think there you'll see less of a
regulation barrier because you're not
editing the actual genetic code you're
just editing the end product so huh all
right well then I guess I have one more
question so people in Silicon Valley
seem to continually be obsessed with
life extension yeah I always wondered
how that like correlates to even just
fundraising like what gets funded here
people that can live forever finally
have you been following like you know a
calorie restriction you know all of us
obviously you work with cancer too as
related yeah what what is what is real
and what is just like hype right now
that people are paying attention to
regarding life extension yeah I think
this
it's a challenging space as a scientist
for the main reason being that there
isn't really a says-- so you know how is
just talking about earlier on like
models that you can use to understand
the biological mechanism of a disease so
for example in cancer you can say if I
create certain genetic mutations in a
normal cell it then turns into a cancer
cell and I can tell that because it does
certain things that it wouldn't do if it
was not a cancer cell so it will form a
tumor and a mouse or it will grow and in
suspension we are a normal cell wouldn't
and so these like these kind of basic
assays that you can use to understand
better what you're looking at with aging
or longevity that is you know more
challenging in the sense that you know
in model systems we have C elegans is a
good model that they use a lot where
they're looking at these nematode worms
and saying like how long they normally
live and like can we extend their life
but a lot of that research it's
difficult to know how it translates into
humans so you don't have like really a
good endpoint and the human system so
people have used like telomeres as
telomere length it's like an endpoint
but I don't think that is very well
established so you actually you know see
a lot of noise and that particular
endpoint and so it's hard to know if you
do this intervention and a nematode and
it extends the lifespan if you do that
invention and you do the intervention in
humans you're gonna have to wait a
really long time to know whether it
actually worked and so that clinical
study is very difficult if you don't
have a secondary endpoint you can
measure okay so think about cancer
research that you always are looking at
you know extension of life or reduction
of tumor size and these are in patients
we are you know they have advanced
disease so you're gonna see in a very
short window if most of them are going
to die in one year you can quickly see
this the drug extend their life and you
can actually monitor their tumor size in
real time and say does the drug shrink
the tumor so those are like the
endpoints you're looking at so you can
quickly tell does this drug work so for
their longevity research is like what is
the
in point we can use to say that our
interventions are having an impact in
the clinical setting I think there's
like a lot of interesting research
that's happening certainly I mean
Silicon Valley even made fun of it that
the para bios's workers obviously
fascinating very very interesting work
and I think there's you know the calorie
restriction stuffs been around for a
while there's actually like a lot of
controversy there because there is mixed
effects that you see in different models
so for example in some strains of
rodents if you do calorie restriction it
actually decreases their lifespan and
there's two primate studies that were
done one which it extended lifespan and
wonder what should decrease lifespan so
the work and the preclinical setting and
animal models is pretty mixed for
calorie restriction so I don't know if
it's you know again we don't have that
endpoint to really measure and see if it
works or not and then with para biases
which is the other kind of big trendy
area right now advantage might not just
in case people don't know yeah that's
basically it's kind of terrifying sewing
to animals to get like an old mouse a
young Mouse in like connecting their
blood streams so that they the old mouse
and the young mouse receiving each
other's blood but that's in been done in
a in a less like sort of dramatic way
through actually just harvesting blood
from young mice and injecting it into
old mice so that's that's been done that
way and so there you also see an effect
what hasn't been very successful is
trying to figure out what causes the
effect so when people have tried to
analyze the blood of young mice and old
mice and say what is the growth factor
or the hormone or what is it that's
causing this there's been controversy
over what it is so some people have
published certain factors that other
groups have not been able to reproduce
the effect and so that area is still
unknown okay and obviously if you could
find out what it is that would be huge
because then you can make a recombinant
of it and you wouldn't need to take like
young blood and inject it into old
people you could just take this
recombinant factor or group of factors
and just use that as a supplement as an
injection or whatever it needed to be
okay
so right now it's just like time for
snake oil basically right now is still
very you know very much in that stage of
figuring out yeah figuring out how to
apply it and but there's I mean the hard
part is getting that initial robust
result like the fact that people are
consistently seeing that if you take
young blood and inject it into old mice
that has an impact is actually like very
exciting most things what you most of
time when you're doing doing fundamental
research you're like finding something
that seems interesting but then the more
you study it you realize it was just an
artifact so it's mostly disappointment
the fact that you know people have
consistently seen this is pretty
interesting interesting okay last
question that are you applying any of
the stuff to your daily life do you have
any weird like bio habits that you're
like taking different whether it's like
medicine or supplement or your fasting
anything like that are you doing any of
this stuff so the one thing I am trying
to do but it's so hard is to do fasting
so I used to try to do it every couple
of weeks but honestly I only managed to
do it like once a month okay for me if I
don't eat for a whole day I end up like
just unable to function properly like
I'm really I have to choose like a
Saturday or Sunday where I don't have to
do anything because I can't really
function well enough to do it on a
workday but I definitely think there's a
lot of science there around fasting
improving your metabolic control and
just in general for me when I do it I
feel like my appetite control is a lot
better and it was just like it just
seems to have a good impact going
forward so I definitely like that's one
that I do think people like oh it seems
kind of high P but I think the science
is there so I have 24 hours I do it from
the evening through like the whole next
day through breakfast the next day okay
sounds like 36 36 hours yeah
interesting but yeah you're kind of like
slower during that fasted State well my
brain just doesn't work at all
completely it's completely you know just
have to watch TV or do nothing useful
because I can't think probably but so
that's that's like the downside of it
but I do think it seems like it has um
has some benefits but yeah I don't take
like supplements or nootropics
none of them no none of that I should
probably research more into it but I
haven't so far I'm very interested I
have I have some
you know theories myself around these
things but one of the things I'm very
interesting interested in is individual
responses to food so I think that you
know all of the research has been done
on diet and dietary interventions if you
actually look at the clinical data it
suggests that there's a subgroup of
people that respond to that dietary
intervention very well but the vast
majority don't really at all and so you
get this kind of modest effect so if you
do things like you know Paleo diet or
like you know any of those diets you
have like a small group of people who
actually lose quite a lot of weight and
then you have you know most people don't
really lose much way and so you just
have a small effect and so I think that
it would make sense to me that there's
actually you know different responses as
individual people because if you think
evolutionary about how to have a diverse
population of people you would never
want to be everybody responds the same
way to certain food availability because
if there was you know famine of a
certain type of food you would lose like
the whole population so it kind of makes
sense that you would have diversity and
and who in the types of diets that
people respond well to and so that's an
area where I think there's some initial
data that looks pretty interesting
around personalization of response to
foods what are what are those studies
called out of this fascinating what are
what would I look for Fona learn more I
mean most of what's really like at the
cutting edge there is actually around
measurements of things like insulin
response to certain food types so if you
we're actually wearing like insulin
monitors like continuous insulin
monitors to like look at things glucose
insulin levels trying to understand like
people's response to food for those kind
of key hormones and so that's an area
where that you could probably research
it but it's pretty cool that was pretty
cool yeah all right well thank you for
coming in of course
you